à Mario Paul
un silence inhabituel
jamais en trois semaines nous n'avions
entendu un tel calme
accompagné par les forces séparatistes
prorus nous nous approchons du dernier
bastion ukrainien de la ville
de part et d'autre de cette avenue aux
immeubles ravagés
des drapeaux rouges il délimite un
corridor les Russes ont décrété un cessé
le feu de 4 heures l'usine d'azophtales
n'est qu'à 300 mètres juste là-bas et
c'est là-bas que son retranchés les
combattants
Ukrainiens ne reste que quelques minutes
avant la fin du cessez-le-feu décrété
par les Russes pour leur permettre de se
rendre
soudain un groupe semble arriver de
l'usine les soldats tchétchène autour de
nous sont sur le qui-vive
il s'agit en fait de soldats russes
partis en reconnaissances selon eux
personne n'est sorti de ce côté là
et à 16h précise
un déluge de feu s'abat de nouveau sur
Lucie
à droite on voit une frappe
ces images de drone donnent l'ampleur du
pilonnage des Russes et des séparatistes
sur azophtales
au sol les soldats tchétchène
s'apprêtent à repartir à la sodas
obstacle - on va rentrer immeuble par
immeuble pour les prendre jusqu'à
obstacle
on ne la prend pas commune
à quelques rues de là ces habitants ont
à peine profité de la calmi la peur est
revenue
c'est la peur on a peur il n'y a que les
idiots qui n'ont pas peur nous on a peur
selon cet homme il pourrait encore y
avoir des civils à
la direction avait donné son accord pour
que les ouvriers et leurs familles
puissent s'installer dans la brillant
tibombardement
les Ukrainiens ont diffusé cette vidéo
de femmes et d'enfants disant qu'ils
sont sous l'usine impossible à vérifier
la Russie dément tout en accusant les
Ukrainiens de se servir de civil comme
de boucliers humains